hounds gun grass my name mr. Jack mr.
Sher what're you doing I'm typing I
swear I didn't rape them are you sure
yes of course I'm sure however I'm gonna
rape them like - that's just how I rape
people odd that's not funny
that's that's not funny all right with
chair I'm just gonna go read my
sledgehammer actually I think there's
yep there we go give it to me baby
yes see you later naked guys let me
share I'm watching - you okay baby
whatever you say all right so we need
this sledgehammer and to solve the
puzzle which I totally did not cheat
while and the last episode was I just
figured it out cuz what you don't think
I can figure stuff out my my own it's
natural okay where the [ __ ] are we going
mr. sledgehammer
I think it's this way right here all
right you are quite right to
sledgehammer you know that I'm sorry but
this is too loud it's killing mayors all
right you know what I don't trust you I
am done okay the other thing is oh yeah
this here sure mr. Lane how are you
actually gonna do some good stuff day
all right
proud of myself all right throgh yeah
that's the door like a bus like a I
don't even know like I'm something
CarGurus I don't appreciate oh no I
don't appreciate anyone here they should
problem enter be on key here well what
do you know that's a naked woman's a
strange key that's lovely
I love when kids are strange that's what
she said
oh man I should have like a Nevada for
best joke ever not made I'm sorry okay
let's just keep going
Alex song by alright let's just oh why
do we have here sand in potions how did
I miss them
that's lovely lovely lovely lovely
lovely lovely lovely lovely nah blah
blah huh
what the hell was that what's going on
okay they've exploded that exploded
that's what she said
what is this give it to me alright let's
go
it won't budge I just going on here
what's going on here I do not appreciate
y'all know I know a shelter dad probably
no I'm out of oil god damn it ok alright
school browse I got this okay I don't
got it but whatever you don't judge me
alright okay I don't trust you Jennifer
I'm sorry but what the hell are you
doing oh it's gotta be what where did
they go they totally just disappeared
hello what it says downstairs
oh no that's bad it's the opposite of
upstairs
I got damnit I don't like this I'm sorry
I just don't I don't why I'm sorry but
I'm don't like it it's that guy on the
shadow hey hello can you hear me yeah oh
snap oh no
goddammit everything was beautiful
[Music]
hey that's a fast look where I am I did
I some oh no it's so much oh no I got
too drunk and I ended up being a demon
sacrifice god damn it
happens all the time it's third time
this happened okay let's check what's in
the air send one in here cockroach oh
yeah disgusting
it's just free card let's give me that
ten boxes give it to me
well they escaped that's disgusting oh
no I'm trapped in here and hang on
nope I'm good alright anyone want a
battle anyone want to know how I know
karate because I don't know why Stephano
seriously though it's been a wise and I
met them what's going on I don't like
this place I know I don't like it either
buddy it's teamwork I'm glad we got in
first thing together now we first got a
final engine but to meet him it bow what
are you trying to hide here huh everyone
try oh you left an empty chest oh maybe
there are there's probably a [ __ ] key
alright let's find the key bro the
problem Enter key yes somewhere but
where what are you looking at you're the
one who's naked stop questioning me here
you know that some apple okay where's
the key
I'm sorry but I'm getting really tired
of looking at the keys everywhere though
it's custom oh wait probably here yes
who Beckett I love you okay now get out
of my face that's disgusting you smell
all right let's go here really really I
used two key and you're not gonna know
all right bye that's cool that's cool I
appreciate it I appreciate all the
effort
I'm a demon sacrifice baby all right
let's go here cautious lovely nothing in
them even more lovely it's with all the
candles
I don't own songs all right way oh come
on
okay okay there's no problem it's no
problem it's a big [ __ ] problem and
too big problem it's okay okay okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I didn't mean to throw
that ah holy [ __ ] he's fast he's fast
for a naked person I gotta give him that
[Music]
oh snap snaps never our Hummer god damn
I don't understand how do ya ah he was
freaking fast as hell I just want to
hide in Connor he's like no denying
mother [ __ ] died do you know I should do
the dota voices I'm just saying good dog
oh god damn it it's locked isn't it
boxes why do you do that okay well you
know what actually nevermind alright I
gotta find a Kia some why could it
possibly
maybe wait then I like start here shut
up oh it's open now shut up
no wait I already in here now I'm really
comfortable
no you're as really confused
it's not gonna work this is it oh I'm a
genius
let's get physical right I'm gonna be
PewDiePie right now okay that didn't
even rhyme so I'm sorry I'm sorry for
that joke alright frogging like that's
Magikarp ah what are you doing here go
down the stairs it hurts I don't care
jump in it or do it I don't care
oh [ __ ] barrels cheap try to harass I
don't care stop rolling barrels don't
draw [ __ ] I need to find some kind of
light source you try to hide from me no
you're John it's probably here no all
right we got a key so this riddle and
the darkness will not hide any secrets
from you anymore I've hidden them and
there are four in the room behind with
the closed door close to warm place
under place to relax behind wait
you were not hiding I hidden them okay
close to a warm place probably an oven
under a place to relax probably a bed
behind two closed doors okay in the same
direction as a sky
alright so down at least I can hear a
fire so there's probably want in there
god damn I got my genius whatever
working here can't deny the fact that I
got ok this shet up and sleep with me
wait didn't I have a key oh yeah alright
alright fireplace give me your keys
mom pie place give me your keys no
fireplace fireplace fireplace
but you said you have a key ah ah
Caramba
all right what do we got here I see
something and clicking that [ __ ] what
did I do okay
mayonnaise stop it it's not funny
Barker's trying to hide stuff from me
too I click that [ __ ] all right what
else oh there it is all right I didn't
see it I click that [ __ ] and the
direction towards the sky all right
where exactly is that I don't really see
it I don't have my torture I mean it's
like this shut up so maybe other this
lovely okay I pressed for button did
something happen the barrel start
rolling that's what happened oh man
all right maybe this door opened yes all
right
I love speedy I waited for you Jesus
Christ you scream like a frickin girl
don't scream like a girl yes you do
everyone knows they don't question me
I'm sorry I'm sorry smart all right
honey you're doing try to all my lantern
you're trying to look good in front of
me barrel I don't fall for your tricks
barrel no I don't all right thanks for
breaking the glass ah ha
all right karate barrel smash I can't
get that now yes we got Santa portion
yes we have the eastern honky of two
addicts Sanka lovely absolutely
fantastic I'd pay the let's get out of
here this way they have you safe don't
be scared it's just a freaking light man
up all right man the [ __ ] up
okay I'm sorry it's don't like when it
changes color
well I'm sorry I shouldn't have
sacrificed father that's what you get
for sacrificing repair there he's fast
as hell first I can't run from that I'm
not a freaking marathon Luciano runner
what is it spot are you responsible for
that
now pity I'm sorry I'm sorry I am swear
it wasn't me
are you sure yes of course I would know
I don't trust you
don't you know okay thank you feel kind
of bad now I'm sorry pot barrel get out
of my way
I do toad on Christ in me all right bear
they you are an idiot how daddy Aurelius
leave me with a naked penis monster I
can run by and pissed off I am freakin
pissed
alright alright sorry Stefano it's okay
for now just because we're but else but
if you do it again I might consider
cutting your neck by the neck okay I'll
cut you advice are you happy okay I'm
sorry he's not even here and I'm talking
sorry all right let's lazy Savannah
Savannah oh no don't fall down it what
the hell is this why here
what are you daddy you lock that door
ice cream it's okay I forgive you Maude
developer all right Beryl don't just try
to stand there just awkward I'm sorry
petty I'm sorry I'm terribly sorry
I don't care you got apologies I don't
know good here go oh snap you soon look
at that emerged with a map that's what
happened if you're evil that's like oh
snap I
well it's of wasting your life why did
you tell Omar of them murder then why
don't you tell me stop waiting my lad
and I would totally do it
so where's it stopped I heard you the
last name job wait seriously I don't
even have it on what do you want from me
all right okay so why do we got nothing
don't make love it's disgusting
maybe there's a key here maybe there's a
key here no maybe it's there so oh no I
don't like this this is creepy
vana are you in here I don't depreciate
dish hello hello anyone want to fight
because I don't I will run so then if
two people want to fight then I just
I'll just get out of there and while ahh
I don't trust you okay
Oh No what is this hey all right lovely
lovely lovely lovely experiments and
stuff right I remember this map design I
just
is it bad yes I do think food
oh snap what just happened I think the
constant sorry bug I've been in this map
before is he using the same maps
sometimes when you change map it changes
to another custom story something game
that's what happened or maybe he was
just lazy
I'm not sure
Wow what the hell let's just go with it
what didn't know say I can't believe ya
I already played this what the hell what
the hell all right what should i do then
no this sucks I wish I could actually
play cousin sorry that's uh I'm sorry
Bruce I have to end it here they totally
bug and I promise this
I don't know that cuz they're Friday's
right video took me forever let me see
if I can fix it for to tomorrow and I'll
be back then with discussing story until
then like baby if you enjoy discussion
should I leave again
apparently if you win one time you can
do it again so and it was a pretty
unanimous decision that you bros wanted
to crown me king of the web so i don't
know what it is but let's grab our
torches and let's raid dish